well on the anniversary of that day that
changed the world and led the u.s to
launch its war on terror the taliban
sent defined signals from the afghan
capital they were in power in
afghanistan on september 11th of 2001
and are now back running the country on
saturday the group raised their flag
over the presidential palace in kabul
u.s led nato forces invaded the country
shortly after 9 11 toppling the regime
that provided sanctuary to al-qaeda the
taliban retook afghanistan just a few
weeks ago
the taliban raised their flag over the
afghan presidential palace in kabul the
day the west mourned those lost in the
september 11 attacks of 2001.
the 20th anniversary of 911 comes just
weeks after america's chaotic withdrawal
from afghanistan
washington's former embassy in kabul
completely deserted only american
hardware and taliban fighters remain the
islamists are still intensely defiant
and distrusting of washington's motives
past and present
the u.s did not attack afghanistan to
topple the afghan government
their main goal was china russia iran
and all the countries of central asia
these were their goals but they didn't
achieve them
the white taliban flag painted at the
entrance of the former u.s embassy
leaves no doubt as to who are in charge
now
and some people say they're happy that
the taliban have taken control
dozens of female students at the kabul
university held a rally on saturday to
show their support for the taliban they
say the islamists have been portrayed
badly by foreign media
this comes after days of protests which
saw many afghan women demonstrating
against the group demanding
representation in the new administration
and for their rights to be protected
many in kabul are wary of the taliban
but blame the u.s for their current
misfortunes
when the us was here there was a lot of
commotion in our country women were
unveiled
what has america done to us the majority
of our youth fled many were martyred and
many others were afflicted by the us
through war and misery
20 years after the 9 11 attacks the
taliban are back in control in
afghanistan
and for more i'm joined now by
journalist franz marty he's covering
events from kabul for us friends a very
symbolic gesture there by the taliban
the timing unlikely to be a coincidence
what message were the taliban trying to
send with the hoisting of their flag on
september 11th
it is symbolic i wouldn't tie this to
september 11 though because the taliban
haven't said officially a word about 9
11
there have been like no commemoration in
jihadi circles it was apparently
celebrated
but not from the taliban side in fact
taliban fighters that i talked to on
september 11
had no idea that it was this date um so
this is not high on the list of the
taliban um taliban flags have been all
over the city before uh so it is
probably rather coincidence that it fell
on 9 11 that they finally hosted it on
the presidential palace which they have
taken over on 15th of august
now when they returned to power the
taliban promised a general amnesty to
their enemies now it's being reported
that the brother of the head of the
anti-taliban coalition in the panchayat
valley has been shot dead by taliban
forces at a checkpoint
what do you make of that
it's hard to verify the exact
circumstances um because telephones are
shut off in punch here and what comes
from the taliban and the resistance
front is a highly biased propaganda so
what exactly happened is unclear of
course if uh the reports are true that
he was shot uh unarmed and and trying to
to leave the country uh that would of
course be like a
breach of uh rules of of warfare um
could also be that he uh died in
fighting it's really it can't be
definitively said um i wouldn't
overstate his importance uh honestly
before he was killed
there was barely anyone speaking about
amula saleh's brother
and other figures in the resistance are
arguably way more important than he was
i want to discuss something else with
you an investigation by the new york
times is suggesting that the us's last
drone strike in afghanistan before
ending this 20-year mission there may
have struck an innocent aid worker who
had actually worked with a
california-based non-profit and applied
for resettlement in the u.s what do you
know about the circumstances of the
strike
the strike was certainly a budget
operation
the u.s officials themselves
acknowledged to the new york times that
they didn't know who exactly they were
targeting it was a so-called signature
strike so uh according to u.s
surveillance uh the target behaved in a
way that is or was according to to their
assessment consistent
with a terrorist
even if this should have been true
there have been reports that uh
confirmed reports that several children
died in this strike so um even if he
would have been involved somehow
to kill all these children as collateral
damage is hardly uh
squared with with uh the
u.s general's statement that this strike
was a righteous act
it is always hard to verify i have
gotten reports that maybe uh one man
that was killed that they might have had
some links to militants uh that couldn't
be definitively confirmed and it's it's
very difficult but uh the strike was
certainly not this precision strike that
the americans made it
uh look like
friends marty in kabul good speaking to
you as always
you